foreign
[Music]
for those of you who don't know me my
name is Megan Harris I am a data
scientist at Memorial Sloan Kettering
cancer center and I'm here today because
I have a story to tell you all about
data pipelines in R but before I get
into that I do have a quick question for
all of you you don't have to answer me
out loud but when you see this image
does it make you feel anything
or have any ideas on what it is
well this is my personal 100 accurate
representation of a data Pipeline and
now you're all thinking I'm out of my
mind and I might be but hear me out of
course this isn't it this isn't an
actual data pipeline right but rather
the mental images and feelings I had
when I was tasked with making a data
pipeline from scratch in my last
position as a data specialist
the story I want to tell you all today
is about how I created that pipeline in
R within the context of me being a
self-taught r programmer those of us
that work in data when we think of data
pipelines I sure as hell hope it does
not look like that but hopefully it
looks maybe something more like this a
perfect data pipeline
clean processes clean structures great
results
this is a pipeline to most of us but in
the last position I was in the pipeline
looked nothing like that at all if we
could even say there was a pipeline it
was very clunky no structure no
automation just bad vibes and
recklessness
so although I have learned a lot and I
have so much to share I don't have a lot
of time to talk y'all will be lucky if
we get under 19 minutes I'm gonna be
honest so I pulled out four main points
that I learned about creating pipelines
during this journey
these are going to touch on my first
encounters within the data and the
pipeline the importance of identifying
the environmental structures of the
pipeline embedding validations within
the pipeline and understanding what
sustainability looks like for the
pipeline now keep in mind that all of
these main points could easily be their
own talks their own lectures their own
courses so I'll only touch on the
biggest takeaways however I have created
a list of example pipeline scripts
actual shell template documents that you
guys can all use that is in the repo for
this talk on GitHub
yes I know great right
so with that out of the way I think the
best thing for me to do is go back to
the beginning during those first
encounters I had with this Pipeline and
guys I know I'm gonna sound really out
of my mind again but the very first
thing I learned about making data
pipelines in R was to not open r
now I know you're thinking Megan we're
at rstudio comp what are you talking
about I know but hear me out let me give
you some context
this was me on my first day as a data
specialist my first professional data
position I am self-taught so I'm already
coming in not familiar with things but
I'm also not familiar with the subject
matter this position was dealing with
opioid data right there was a lot of
data existing everywhere and the
organization I was working directly with
did not have any structure in place nor
did they have any expectations about
what I was to do
so if I am a new self-taught programmer
newbie and I'm coming in with no
Direction what did I do
so just like this dude is jumping head
first to get to the Winchester shout out
to Sean of the Dead I also dove in head
first into our studio as soon as I got
any data and that's what I did whenever
I got a new data set I tried to create
our programs immediately and what I
should have done was actually started
investigating I didn't ask basic
questions I didn't ask for code books I
didn't try to validate anything it was
just recklessness and Vibes I told you
guys but I argue this point of not
opening our studio with an example of
something that happened to me that was
traumatic I call it the Narcan story now
for those of you who don't know Narcan
is a medication that is used to reverse
opioid overdoses so of course working
with this type of data I'm going to see
this information at some point one day I
get a data set and there's a variable in
it called Narcan and like I did opened
up rstudio quickly looked at it and saw
oh Narcan has numbers in it okay numbers
so without doing anything else I
immediately start making automated
reports dashboards I'm feeling like I am
a freaking Superwoman man I'm awesome
and you know I just I woke up in the
middle of the night like months after
that
and I had just a random just Eureka
moment kind of felt like something was
wrong I woke up and I was like um
something ain't right Chief what is it
so I went to our studio ID opened it up
and I saw a value
and it was four plus and guys my heart
sunk because four plus is not a number
four plus is a string so for months I
was calculating off of this variable
that I did not even know how but I was
coercing a character variable into a
numeric variable so imagine the
embarrassment of going back after
everyone's relying on me for this and
being like hey guys
um it's wrong
so that was just one example of many
times that happened to me all right and
clearly you can see here I learned a lot
but the main thing I learned was to not
jump into R Studio as soon as you get a
data set if you do want to jump into it
only use it to give you a little bit of
context a little bit of Clues so that
you can ask more information it was a
really hard lesson that I had to learn
to just go through this iterative
process of asking questions but doing so
gave me just a little bit more clarity
so remember how that pipeline looked
like in my head when I dove in head
first with no information well now that
I've had an investigation it looks still
messy okay it looks messy and it doesn't
seem like much change but I guarantee
you this is a different picture okay but
just enough started to clear up so that
I could accept that fact that I needed
to start building on this I needed to
make some structure
so in this point we're going to try to
add some environmental structure right
so the biggest thing I learned about
environmental structures is that Theta
pipelines can actually exist in two
types of environments something that I'm
terming as external and internal
environments now there's probably way
more sophisticated ways so think about
this and break this down but I'm a
beginner and this what is what my
beginner brain like made sense this is
what made sense
so when starting out I had realized I
had external things outside of my
computer that was affecting the data
inside of my computer but also things
inside of my computer inside of our
studio that was affecting it as well
and I'll explain both of them so when I
say external environment I'm talking
about more abstract Concepts I'm talking
about any kind of data interactions
decisions admin policies that can affect
the flow of the data even the technology
that's used for data collection and even
the data literacy of whoever you are
working with it was so important to
identify all of these Concepts because
at some point they are going to affect
your internal flow of your pipeline it's
going to affect how you end up working
with and structuring your data
internally
now the internal environment is what
most people think about when they hear
the words data pipeline they think about
the actual file structures the flow of
things happening internally the logic of
processing and even the data security
and storage methods now it should go
without saying that this isn't the
reality right we don't have two separate
environments that exist in silos there's
external things that affect internal
things and vice versa and this is a
challenge that most every data person
knows well even if we don't think about
environments in this way
I'm sure that if any of you work in
non-profit or Academia or government or
anywhere you probably have some form of
bureaucracy affecting what you do maybe
even conflicting interests and decisions
that's an example of this so what helps
me to better navigate the interactions
between these two environments was to
repeatedly tackle each environment by
introducing some structure some
documentation for one and adjusting for
the other
so I just want to give a really quick
example of just some documents that I
made to try to help me out with this so
when I was thinking about structuring my
external environment you guys got to
remember I was a one-person data team
really I was I was the only person
coding an R so everyone else that I was
working with had no concept of this did
not do any coding whatever so my method
of trying to introduce some structure
was to get everybody on the same page so
for this example I have up here making
metadata and very Loosely metadata is
literally just data about data what
helped me help everybody else around me
to kind of help me with what they wanted
was to make sure that they understood
what was happening so what was the name
of the file like for the data how often
was it collected how was it collected
those simple things we don't think about
it really helps to have it documented
somewhere
another example I have is something that
I'm terming as assess attempt repeat we
all do this how many of you have got to
a new organization saw the way that they
were doing something it was just like um
this ain't right so you get in you
assess your situation all right and you
attempt to make a change now if we're
lucky it's the attempt is successful and
it's great and what usually happens is
that we either have people who have been
there that's just like we're not doing
that or something just doesn't work so
when I tried to do this I would try to
make the change outside externally maybe
in a way that we collect data or
anything but nine times out of ten I
ended up having to compromise and make
up for it internally in my systems
So speaking of internally there's also
some examples of introducing some
structure this way
so the first example I have here is
simply named make clean file structures
and this is so much more than like oh
making sure your folder names are clean
and making sure your data is in a data
folder your scripts are in a script
folder this also encompasses knowing how
to work with our project files this
encompasses knowing where you are in
your working directory knowing knowledge
about working directories because that's
the only way that you're going to get a
full flow automation process with
everything stored organized in a good
way and seamless Okay and like I said if
you need to know more about working
directories or our project files or
anything Jenny Bryan and all of the
amazing people have already made
resources for it especially with the
here package and that is linked on my
repill I'm not going to act like I I
know about that so much the next example
I have is something that I'm terming is
modulizing your code now in this example
it's being modulized by data and
component so this is a snip from an
actual large project I had where I had
so many data sources right so it made
sense for me to do the work for each
data source within one script now that's
only one way to do it you know that's
that's
it might work for you and it might not
you know but another example that you
can also do is modulizing your code by
function or by process and I usually do
this when I don't have too many data
sources and I have a more manageable
project now in this example I'm showing
three scripts in my working directory
here I have a docking script which I'll
explain that in the next slide I have a
processing script which is just for
doing Transformations and cleaning and I
have a visual visualization script or a
viscript for short which is literally
just making visits right
so what helped me with these projects
was having individual scripts that I
could call on when it was time to use it
in the pipeline
so the last example I have here for
structuring internal environments is
something that I'm calling connecting
and chaining where it makes sense and
honestly I could have just called it
docking scripts I don't know why I talk
too much so an example of a docking
script is on these next few slides and I
want to stress the importance of like
the content in it is not so much
important but just the logic of what is
happening is now in my terms in my Megan
brain a docking script is one R script
that will literally bring in your data
do your cleaning your validation do
everything that it needs to do so that
when you hit that source button at the
top everything does what it needs to do
and your end result is hopefully a
deliverable that you're looking for
whether it is a shiny app or a clean
data set
so just to get into it just a little bit
the docking script starts just like any
other R script will start we'll load in
our libraries then the next section
we'll go into is something that I call
the data process check here now this
looks maybe hopefully not complicated
but this is literally just bringing in
your data and then determining how you
want to have some logic values so if you
want to do something to check like very
simply down here this last line it's
just checking a new data set against an
old data set to see if the value of rows
changed and I don't recommend doing that
I don't have time to get into why but
don't do it but you'll get a logic value
at the end of this section so then the
next section I have here is a logic flow
for processing so this is just very
simple if scripts if statements so if
the data has updated we will then tell R
to Source one of our marginalized codes
we will tell r that okay if there's new
data go ahead and process that data if
there's new data go ahead and make a
visualization for it so that can look
very complicated obviously depending on
what you got going on in your project
but after all of that is done you can
embed options in your docking scripts to
render your output so in this case it's
a simple HTML report and an example of a
working hopefully working version of
this is on the repo you can see so
now that I've zoomed by that and
realized that oh I needed environmental
structure my data pipeline looks like
this in my head
I still don't know what this is and I'm
really anal so I hate that the lines are
crooked like that so what can I do to
try to clear up the image of my mental
data pipeline
well we can add data validations and let
me tell you guys I am exposing myself
here because you guys know what I
learned about data validations
I learned that you have to do them
because if you do not check yourself you
will indeed wreck yourself you
absolutely will okay I'm gonna be honest
I am not the person to stand up here
talking about validations I am still
learning myself okay but I can tell you
that the most important thing that I
learned was to do them because man I
could have saved myself so much pain if
I had just checked that damn variable
man oh my God so what I can do is just
give you some examples of some types of
validations that I did run into now I
won't go into all of these specifically
this is kind of here just for a think
piece so if any of you are doing the
same you can reference this and be like
hmm do I have data that fits this as
well
now something that I did actually learn
on my own is that validations can exist
externally and internally so in my case
or in my opinion The best scenario has
always been that validations are
implemented externally whether that's at
the point of data collection or whatever
if it's extra it's if it's externally
implemented it might increase the
chances of your data being actually like
workable and clean by the time it gets
to you internally hopefully it's less
work but my usual scenario has been that
there's no validation done and that I
have to do everything and it feels like
it's way more work than it needs to be
but that's just me right so okay I
realize I have to do validations that's
the thing I did the manually and R and
there's nothing wrong with that but it
can be cumbersome but there's packages
guys I didn't know this
um shout out to Crystal Lewis because
she told me about the point blank
package I was late like I literally
learned about it two days ago I had to
change my slides so this is here for
both of us to or for all of us to learn
together so if you are also in the dark
like I was we can learn together because
I don't know about validations you just
got to do them guys so okay now that we
have determined that we needed data
validation this is what my pipeline
looks like now I see some shapes but I'm
going to be honest with you guys I still
don't like those lines so what else can
I add
so our last point is sustainability okay
so
um sustainability can mean and look like
a lot of different things and I'm going
to be honest guys because I was a
one-person data team I did not have any
bandwidth to do any type of real
sustainability effort but what I was
able to do was kind of look at the work
that I did do see okay what is really
going to count for sustainability or
what's going to help with this Pipeline
and what do I wish I could have done
so this is just a quick list of things
that I brainstormed with like man like
if I had the time to do it I wish I
could but the things that I did
highlight and saw here are things that I
actually eventually did get to do before
I had left that last position and my
point of putting this up here again is a
think piece slide so what I want all of
you to take away from this part of the
um session is to kind of ask yourself do
you or your organization wherever you're
working with your data do you guys have
sustainability efforts in place or are
you in a cyclic cycle of just reaching
the next deadline and if so are there
ways to start incorporating making some
sustainability efforts to do some QA or
Qi on your Pipelines
so the last thing I can share with you
guys is just some really really quick
examples of things I tried to do to try
to document right because with me being
a one-person data team the best thing I
had to do was document everything so
that people that didn't code or didn't
do data could understand what needed to
happen especially when I ended up
resigning so that you know my work
didn't just fall apart so this is an
example that I have fully on the repo as
well and this is a data workflow map so
what helped me was actually visualizing
all the different data sources that I
had going into one of my pipelines
literally explaining where it was coming
from but then visualizing what's
happening inside of R for other people
another example I think this looks
really similar to a SQL schema I'm sorry
I suck a sequel so I don't know if
that's true but um pretty much again
just a readable version so that people
that wasn't working in data can look and
say okay we have these data sets and
these are the variables in it and these
are the possible ways we can relate them
to one another
okay so now that I've zoomed by all that
let's let's recap so this was my
pipeline in my head before we did
anything when we just jumped in head
first
this is what it looked like when we
started to investigate that environment
ask questions about the data this is
what it looked like when we added some
structure when we realized data
validation was a thing and when we tried
to add some sustainability and you know
what I still don't know what this is a
picture of
um but I know that it looks kind of
pretty in that it has some clear shapes
some straight lines and some colors and
maybe that's the point right
so if you are someone that's just
starting out in data science or teaching
yourself how to use R like I was
something that you may have learned is
that having things just be functional
can be just enough and sometimes you may
never even know everything about the
data you're dealing with but you can
appreciate the beauty of the unknowns
and the efforts that have been made to
create the pipeline that you do have to
work with of course through time you
want to evolve and use best practices
and feel that we're 100 knowledgeable on
what we do but my hope is that I've
given you guys something useful to take
back a few today to try to make this
process of making data pipelines a
little less painful especially if you're
going to do the same thing than I did
and make them from scratch and are thank
you for listening guys
foreign
[Music]